science is not about finding truth it is
about disproving truth isn't it truth is
not a revelation that is handed down to
us once and for all by higher
authorities gender generally is a social
construct this is a very scary idea for
a lot of people human beings are are are
real things they're not just social
constructs science in the 19th century
gave us this thing called scientific
racism the problem is not science
the problem is collectivism there is no
correspondence between language and
truth language is just a game and you
manipulate logic you manipulate evidence
you use any rhetorical trick in order to
advance your group's value judgment and
morality to me as a form of superstition
progress has been real the status of
women the status of gays the status of
blacks and all of the other races I
never speak the truth I'm telling
stories and you can like them or not I
don't think they're any more true than
any other story about the Holocaust or
about World War two Michele Foucault
said I am simply a Nietzschean and at
what we do know about Nietzsche is
ruthless power politics all the way down
you don't get individual liberty out of
that tonight's resolution reads
post-modernism is necessary for a
politics of individual liberty and again
I want to bring on arguing for the
affirmative
Tydeus Russell Thaddius please take to
the stage and I'll give a negative
Stephen Hicks please Stephen please come
to the stage
[Applause]
and since Thaddeus is arguing for the
negative he will lead off you have 15
minutes to tell us why post-modernism is
what you claim it to be
take it away I'm actually arguing for
the affirmative so that's okay I make
mistakes too and the good thing is since
I'm a postmodernist that doesn't matter
it's just about being interesting not
being right so let's start at a really
important moment in history 1961 I think
is a great moment for freedom individual
freedom this was the year in which two
books were published one by this guy
named Michel Foucault this terrible
French philosopher who everyone hates he
wrote a book called madness madness and
civilization which was simply a history
of the asylum in Europe and North
America in which he talked about what I
think might be the worst use of state
power against human beings or the worst
abuse of state power of human beings in
history if you think about it as you may
know after World War Two and even before
then but certainly after World War two
many many people were locked up in these
asylums which are essentially prisons
for the so-called mentally insane now do
we know who those people were where they
just schizophrenic
no it included women who were simply
promiscuous or who sold sex and it
included people who were known as free
thinkers people who were simply
dissidents people who even believed in
things like opposition to war people who
believed in free markets sometimes
anyone who's thought outside of the
dominant discourse of the time tended to
be locked up in these kinds of places
and reformed by being sedated
sometimes being sterilized sometimes
having electroshock given to them or
lobotomized if none of that worked this
is pretty bad stuff so what that was all
based on the justification for doing
this to these people was these claims
made by medical scientists medical
scientists at the Sorbonne at Harvard at
Columbia at UC Berkeley and at Stanford
and at Oxford and Cambridge medical
scientists using the scientific method
studied a bunch of people and said oh
well if you have these ideas about Paulo
or if you're a woman and has these bad
desires and sleeps around with women or
if you simply are something that we
don't want in our society because you
are weird or different we're gonna have
to do something to you put you away and
reform you and assimilate you into the
dominant norms of our society so that
you can get along here and many of those
people never left those places right I
actually used to live in Salem Oregon
which is the home place of the mental
hospital that is famous for being the
site of the One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest movie that was fun that was fun
they were doing lobotomy is an
electroshock into the 1980s there now
again these were psychiatrists medical
professionals scientists telling the
courts your you need to go there you
need to go there you need to go there
and many of these people most of these
people were not schizophrenic s-- they
were actually people like me they were
like people like you too if you have
divergent ideas or had at divergent
ideas from the dominant norms you were
very likely be locked up in one of those
places Foucault then later wrote a
history of the prison similarly right he
said that it wasn't just people who were
bad or criminals were violent it was
people who were simply different
eccentric crazy and all sorts of waves
in that very same year in 1961 the year
that that fuko's madness and
civilization came out another book was
published by a man named Thomas saws we
are familiar with this right and that
book was called the myth of mental
illness now he didn't make exactly the
same argument as Foucault but it was a
very similar argument he said that these
these ideas about mental illness were
really just myths they were made up they
were made up by the state they were made
up by scientists they were made up of
medical professionals and they were used
to punish people who were simply
aberrant displayed aberrant behaviors in
1961 1961 very important date the next
year next year another really good year
was 1962 this was the year that Thomas
Kuhns structure of scientific
revolutions came out now this argument
was revolutionary and this was really in
many ways the beginning of
post-modernism in some ways it uh it
argued that
that science has changed scientific
truth constantly changes science is not
about finding truth it is about
disproving truth isn't it any science
any scientists you know should be a
postmodernist in fact the real
scientists I think are all postmodernist
they always say this we're never finding
truth were simply disproving claims
about truth right so Thomas Kuhn said
well look at the history of science
again just like Foucault look at the
history of a truth claim any time you
hear a truth claim just read the Sun
read the history of it and Foucault and
Kuhn said in every case here's the thing
there is a history there is a history
these claims these ideas about truth or
truth itself doesn't come out of nature
it doesn't come out of God in every case
you simply look at the history you can
find that there was a point in time
where women who are promiscuous were
considered to be crazy and needed to be
locked up there was a time right then
when people who were considered to be
homosexual were homosexuals were
considered to be crazy and they need to
be locked up as you may know
homosexuality until 1973 was officially
designated by the American Psychiatric
Association as a pathology and many
homosexuals were locked up in those
cages in those mental asylums and
sterilized lobotomized and sedated
Thomas Kuhn said science is always
changing its mind all the time we are
one minute completely convinced as a
society that something is true like the
fact back in the day that the Sun
revolved around the earth everyone just
knew that was true and if you disbelieve
that if you even were skeptical about
that claim what happened to you what
happened to you very bad things because
I was challenging truth that was
supported by the church and the state
and it was universally agreed that the
Sun revolved around the earth that was
the Ptolemaic system right then this guy
named Copernicus came along and said not
so much maybe the Earth revolves around
the Sun
big trouble for him big trouble for
anybody who believed this right and then
Galileo got his his problems too when he
when he followed up on that idea so
again it is this there's an arrogance
here in every moment in history we as a
society are all there's a consensus
around what is true and what is not
right and then a few years later we
change our minds entirely about it so
one minute
everyone's convinced that the Sun
revolves around the earth and the next
minute everyone is convinced just the
opposite how do we know today that we
are right even about that if we were so
wrong about it before back in the day
not even that long ago we considered
this to be completely solid right
completely solid no space in there well
what do we think now there's atoms and
there's spaces between them this is as
full of holes as it is of hard matter
solid matter right completely radical
idea that could have gotten you burned
at the stake or thrown in a prison or an
asylum are we still are we convinced now
that these scientific truths are true
forever
when is a truth that is a claim about
something being universal everywhere
eternal always and applying to all
people that's a heavy claim to make in
any case right so Kuhn really pulled the
rug under from out under from that and
people started to follow that in post
modernist theory Jacques Derrida the
most evil man on earth according to
Jordan Peterson later in the 1960s began
writing several books and articles in
which he argued that there is no
correspondence between language and
truth there was a common belief it's
still pretty common now that we can
ascertain we can arrive at we can find
truth through language is that true is
that true he said no not so much
because language always changes and all
the words refer to everyone every other
word when you look in a dictionary at
synonyms of words what do you find you
find just word after word after word
describing the other words there is no
end to it there is no word that is
closer to the truth in any other in this
case now what was Derrida inspired by he
was inspired like Foucault by the abuses
of government by the state in the 20th
century and in fact he said his
inspiration for inventing the idea of
deconstruction deconstructing language
and texts and showing that there are
internal contradictions and that there
is no absolute correspondence between
language or words and truth he can't it
came from rejecting these claims made by
governments that with the use of
scientists that owes things like you
know Jews are vermin right or women who
are aberrant and don't behave properly
need to be locked up or that blacks are
biologically inferior to whites
these are language claims about truth
that needed to be deconstructed that was
his impetus was actually an opposition
to state abuses of powers through
language you don't have a law without
norms and language upholding them which
involved truth claims so that is to me
the origins of what should have been an
alliance between lovers of personal
liberty and these so-called post
modernists but it didn't happen
unfortunately then later in the 1970s we
had the advent of post modernist
feminism which said that again women and
gender generally is a social construct
this is a very scary idea for a lot of
people but if you think about it gender
has changed what it means to be a woman
has changed over time it changes
constantly what it means to be a man has
changed constantly the ideal feminine
has changed constantly the ideal
masculine has changed constantly across
time across history and across space
different countries different societies
think of these things differently and
always have and even in this country we
have changed radically in our in our
views of what is a good and proper and
ideal man and a good and proper and
ideal woman
their contingent their contingent they
are not eternal that means that they
come from the minds of human beings not
from nature or God in 1979 Jean Francois
leotard another terrible French
postmodernist argued against these what
he called meta-narratives these claims
that there are that there are currents
in history that just are ineluctable
that they that they happen regardless
that they are not contingent that in
particular progress is inevitable right
this is third of the Whiggish idea of
history that the further we go along the
better we get well here's the thing
these guys all of them were born in the
mid twentieth century right and so they
saw what happened they saw what happened
in the 20th century what happened in the
20th century this was the culmination of
enlightenment scientific thinking wasn't
it World War two this was the
mobilisation of scientists and engineers
to build all those tanks and bombs and
airplanes that killed 65 million people
just in one war same thing in World War
one that was the use of scientific
knowledge to wreak terrible havoc on
massive populations so we began to claim
we began to question science itself it
can be useful it can build bridges and
it can build airplanes but it can also
build tanks that can drive across those
bridges to lay waste to villages it can
also build atomic bombs that are dropped
from those airplanes science and the
Enlightenment can bring the best and it
can bring the worst it is not just a
forward progress it is not just good and
it is not a religion the idea that
science is scientists and science should
be respected and revered and believed on
its face is possibly the most dangerous
belief system ever they said and I agree
if we simply agree that scientists are
always right then they were right about
eugenics they were right about
scientific racism
they were right about scientific sexism
they were right about some of the worst
horrors that have ever been visited on
human beings in history these are all
scientific projects the idea of mental
illness as a pathology of aberrant
behavior as a pathology again that was
invented by medical professionals and
scientists in the name of science so we
must always be skeptical of science
don't reject it this is another thing
that's confused about post-modernism no
post modernist it says don't don't
listen to science don't ever fly in an
airplane it's very useful within the
sphere we live in in the world we live
in but always be skeptical and whenever
anyone makes a claim about any truth
claim any truth that is rooted in nature
or God be careful and maybe reach for
your gun then there was a confusion and
I have two minutes of try to do this
quickly that was really tragic for me
and very frustrating I'm this is why I'm
talking about these days in in 2016
sorry I should say 2013 there was this
new beast created this thing called the
social justice warrior on college
campuses these are the people running
around saying I was born with a penis
but I was also born a man and you must
and that means X Y & Z about me you on
the other hand were born a cyst white
male and that means X Y & Z about you
these were essentialist claims this was
a repudiation of post-modernism this is
the opposite of post-modernism when you
are told that you are such-and-such
because of your body and how you were
born that is what the old conservatives
used to do so the sjw's were a
repudiation of post-modernism but a
couple of canadian professors
nonetheless started talking about how
what's going on in college campuses is
the result of this thing called
post-modernism this guy named jordan
peterson whose mentor on this subject is
this man right here have argued that
that is the root of these things but
actually it's just the opposite it is
conflict
I flipped between that politics and what
I've been calling post-modernism so I
urge you to vote in favor of the
proposition libertarianism and
post-modernism are a marriage that could
result in a brand new movement that
could bring real freedom Thanks thank
you Thaddeus arguing for the negative
Stephen Hicks
take it away Stephen so yes
politics of individual liberty is
essentially an Enlightenment and a
modernist project what I'm going to be
arguing there are some elements of
post-modernism as a comprehensive
philosophical package the politics is
just a small part of it what I am going
to argue is that thinkers like dr.
Russell and some others who are
attracted to post-modernism are doing is
taking some of the elements of
post-modernism watering them down and
trying to then forge a compatibility
with individual liberty but this is a
big project so what is post-modernism is
is a huge thing itself what do we mean
by healthy politics individualism and
liberty I'm going to argue that those
have to be at the other end of the
spectrum now I'm going to say as a
philosopher some things about all of the
major branches of philosophy
post-modernism is a comprehensive
assault on all of the elements of
modernism all of the major elements of
the Enlightenment of which the politics
of individual liberty were one of the
crowning achievements can everybody hear
Stephen in the back ok ok sorry good so
I should get a little closer here but I
do want to start with the politics
because while politics is important to
us the yet the politics of individual
liberty politics is also important to
the post modernists and there's a couple
of ways of going at this one is to look
at the philosophical themes of
post-modernism in their history dr.
Russell does some of that the other is
of course is to sample what the leading
post modernists have said and dr.
Russell did a very good job identifying
who the important thinkers are here
Michele Foucault is certainly one Jean
Francois Liat are another Jacques
Derrida certainly another I'm going to
add to that mix
richard rorty the most important of the
american postmodernists as well so on
the political starting points of the the
leading post modernists Michele Foucault
consider his philosophical political
evolution and these are combined for him
in the 1950s he was a member of the
French Communist Party card-carrying
true believer in the entire package he
did break with the French Communist
Party by the 1960s he was declaring
himself a Maoist that is to say a
follower of the program of the Chinese
Communist at that point he did
eventually break with them by the time
we get to the late 1970s he declares
support and admiration of the Islamic
theocratic revolution in Iran so this is
a man who does change his mind about
political views over the course of the
decades but there is nothing
fundamentally liberal in his evolution
moving on to Richard Rorty
by our context the American standards
he's about as far left as you can go he
considers himself a radical social
democrat and that is a position that he
maintains when after the fall of the
Berlin Wall and the collapse of the
Soviet Union he is asked to reflect on
the terrible brutal real horrible evil
regimes that have come out of the far
left rorty's response was this quote I
think a good left is a party that always
thinks about the future and doesn't care
much about our past sins so an
abdication of moral responsibility we
can tell a different story put a
different interpretation on it we don't
have to take the facts seriously and
that is of course part of the
philosophical poison that we're dealing
with Jean Francois leotard as long a
Philly ated with a group called
socialism or barbarism in the early days
it was a movement that was straight-up
Bolshevik but then as things got bad
under Lenin and then under Stalin they
broke away and became Trotskyite so
again there's an evolution but not at
all a liberal
evolution finally jacques derrida most
famous for his theory of deconstruction
wishes comes out of technical philosophy
of language but toward the end of his
career he he made the following comment
about deconstruction and his commitments
to post-modernism he says and I will
quote deconstruction never had any
meaning or interest to me and my eyes
except as a radicalization that is to
say also within the tradition of a
certain Marxism in a certain spirit of
Marxism right now what we do have then
is a series of thinkers and these are
the big guns who are coming out of very
far left politics but it's not just
politics and they do change but they do
not change at all in the direction
toward liberalism and the reason for
that makes very good sense when you look
at the underlying philosophical
commitments of course Marxism is a
comprehensive philosophical package it's
not just in economics it's not just in
politics it has a theory that's
metaphysics it has an epistemology it
has an understanding of human nature it
has an ethics there's an entire package
and I suppose if you wanted to essential
eyes it there are probably 16 important
claims that Marxism makes all of the
leading post modernists in the 50s and
1960s are breaking away from classical
Marxism because they recognize the brute
the failures of it and they are shifting
in various directions and in many cases
they are critical as dr. Russell points
out about some of the horrible top-down
authoritarian abuses of power by
far-left regimes but being opposed to
certain species of authoritarian in
positions of power is not to be a
liberal there's lots of other places on
the political spectrum one can move away
from certain abuses of state power and
still not at all be anything like a
liberal or a libertarian and that is
what characterizes all of the postmarks
and that makes sense when we start to
look at their underlying metaphysical
views there is skepticism in
epistemology there's social construction
understanding of human nature rather
than being individualistic and then the
the corresponding
very jaded views about the possibility
for peace between human beings the
possibilities that we can work out
win-win transactions the the they do
remain in the in the camp of believing
that human beings are fundamentally in
conflict that it's always power
domination and somebody's going to win
someone is going to lose so this has
been an emphasis on the politics and
I've emphasized the Marxist roots but I
do not at all want to make the claim
that post-modernism is Marxism there is
an evolution here through neo Marxism
zon to various forms of cultural Marxism
and if you look at the history of the
far left the far left is a multi-faceted
menti splinter group and postmoderns do
not all occupy the same space but what
is true to say is that all of them all
of the major and the first two
generation postmoderns are
philosophically committed to anti
liberal politics all the way down and
it's important here then that the four
post modernists that we've mentioned so
for all of them are PhDs they're very
politically engaged politically active
individuals but they are PhDs and
they're not PhDs in history or in in
economics they're all PhDs in philosophy
and that's important because what they
are doing is getting their PhDs in the
1950s at a moment when philosophy has
reached a very skeptical phase and it's
going to be this skepticism and the
consequent subjective isms and
relativism that leads to a hollowing out
of all of the rest of philosophy from
the postmodern perspective and so
there's a repackaging that's that has to
go on here but let's say a few things
about the the philosophical stance that
it's not just a political stance that's
being taken here Richard Rorty for
example will say that the postmodern
task is to figure out what to do now
that both the age of faith that is to
say that that was a near stretch from
say the collapse of the Roman Empire on
into the Renaissance and the rent
information when essentially our
religious philosophy dominated
failed that collapse the postmodernist
say that entire super naturalistic
facebait faith-based tradition top-down
institution based tradition as they
understand it that is a failure but also
Rory goes on to argue the enlightenment
itself also seems to be quote beyond
recovery so that is to say the entire
modern project that there is a natural
world that we can understand through the
application of are using our independent
judgment reason and then in more
complicated cases sophisticated
scientific method and we need to
continue to develop those methods of
scientific method an understanding that
human beings are individuals with their
own independent judgment they're not
born into caste memberships or racial
memberships or anything that we should
treat peoples as individual with their
own capacity to form their own judgments
and govern their own lives and then the
consequent to rest of the Enlightenment
project what the postmoderns are arguing
is that entire package is wrong now what
that means metaphysically in terms of
our understanding of reality is that the
post moderates are what we call
anti-realist so they will say yes for
2500 years the history of philosophy
we've been arguing about whether God
exists or not that is to say we've been
arguing is the natural world is
cause-and-effect world the
self-contained world is that it or is
there a supernatural world as well so
that debate they want to say well we've
been arguing about it for a long time
nobody knows what the answer to that is
and that is to say we should stop asking
that question what is the nature of
reality is that the natural world or is
it the supernatural world is ultimately
a meaningless question right we started
to put to reality in quotation marks we
start to put the word truth in quotation
marks and distance ourselves right from
that but of course if we're interested
in a politics of Liberty about one of
the big arguments of the Enlightenment
is we need you know we live in the real
world and the real world gives us
feedback it's important for every
individual to have the confidence and
the competence in his or her
increasingly her own judgment so that
they can understand the way the world
actually is in order to live
successfully in it if you
philosophically back away from that
claim and start saying well there is no
such thing as reality there are only
interpretations of yours there's mine
reality starts to drop out of the
picture you're not going to support a
politics of individual liberty it's also
important that the the enlightenment was
for the first time in history a
consistently individualistic philosophy
that individuals are the unit of reality
we're not fragments of a supernatural
being we're not born into a class we're
not pre assigned to gender rules each
individual has competence has agency as
a basic respect and that is to be
captured universally so yes absolutely
the modernists and the Enlightenment are
gung-ho about the importance of a big
meta-narrative all women should have
equal rights slavery is a moral
abomination and we need to get rid of it
that's a huge meta-narrative every human
being has the birthright of Liberty
those are meta-narrative claims and what
justifies them is an epistemology that
says we can figure out truths yes truth
is very complicated sometimes and
sometimes we only have probabilistic
knowledge sometimes we're just
speculating sometimes we make mistakes
but if we apply our independent judgment
well we can individually and socially
self correct and acquire better and
better knowledge through these concepts
are ones that we need to maintain it's
important then to note that the leading
post modernists do not see people as
individuals they explicitly reject the
individualism Richard Rorty the least
radical of them says somewhat
apologetically you know this is a direct
quote we are in fact
stuck in our ethnocentric predicament so
his position is for individuals their
ethnicity is in fact the fundamental
shaping part of their identity that we
all have to think of ourselves in
ethnocentric ways and
different ethnicities have different
histories and different value framers
necessarily they're going to be in
conflict with each other so that then is
to say we're anti individualistic and we
are saying is not possible to solve
these historical problems and so forth
so it's a very pessimistic and cynical
position some of the post modernists of
course come at it less from an
ethnocentric perspective but they do
focus on linguistic issues dr. Russell
mentions Derrida and he is the most
famous proponent of this view here and
there's a there's a one thesis there's
actually several of them here but the
most important one here is the product
of the view that language is a social
product and that human beings come into
the world they don't have individual
agencies they don't have the ability to
understand the world individually in
terms of their own contact instead the
language that they are born into shapes
fundamentally how they think and and and
operate in the world and gives them
their values and so therefore we are all
prisoners of our linguistic background
now of course if you take that position
now I think that philosophy of language
is entirely wrong but it is exactly the
one that the post modernists buy into
and that is to say it is anti
individualistic your very thinking and
your values is a product of a group
linguistic structure that pre-existed
you there's no way to get from that
postmodern position to anything
approaching a respect for individualism
and then finally when we turn to the the
ethos all of the postmoderns without
exception Richard Rorty again to a
lesser degree retain not the classical
Marxist exploitation theory but as
Derrida says in the spirit of Marxism
the view that human relations across
multiple dimensions are deeply
exploitative it is this race against
that race it is these rich people
against these poor people it is the the
white people against those people it's
men versus women and all of them are
constructed by different groups and so
the conflict is necessarily going to be
inescapable it also means that since we
are skeptical about reason we're not
going to be able to get past those
differences think about our confidence
in the free market or demo
kradic Republican politics that's all
about saying human beings can take
agency we can have our differences but
we can just talk about them we can point
to common facts and come to some sort of
peaceful agreement and so forth if you
think that human beings are divided into
different groups and they do not have
that rational agency as a matter of
principle then you're going to say
democratic politics doesn't make sense
the free market doesn't make sense
instead all you're left with is naked
power struggles Michele Foucault said I
am simply a Nietzschean and at what we
do know about Nietzsche is a ruthless
power politics all the way down you
don't get individual Liberty out of that
[Applause]
five minutes to rebuttal from various so
I and Jean and Foucault and Derrida all
have something in common we all began
our political careers as Marxists now if
you were to look at my career as a whole
all my writing all my speaking and genes
I think you would not take away from
that that we are Marxists at all I think
you would take away from that that we
are very clearly anti-marxist and
anti-communist that is also true for
Foucault and Derrida how do we know this
because Noam Chomsky Fredric Jameson and
every Marxist I've ever known I mean
serious Marxist hate the guts of
post-modernism
why because Marxism is based on this
idea of historical materialism which is
that materialism the material matters in
society economics institutions the state
the material in the nature that is
what's real and everything else is
immaterial or less important things like
ideas and culture right now that is
exactly counter to what Marxists have
said right I mean sorry that's exactly
counter what to post modernist who said
they have said that no there is no such
thing as a natural truth an eternal
absolute truth outside of human
consciousness I had a friend who was a
Marxist professor at Columbia who said
to me once are you reading all that
French horseshit up there we can't stand
that [ __ ] because it distracts us from
the real work the true work of
revolution they also believe that
capitalism inevitably results in
socialist revolution don't they that's
an essentialist Naturalist claim right
that in capitalism is ass intrinsic self
destructive quality right and that the
proletariat
will inevitably necessarily naturally be
the vanguard of that revolution it's all
superstitious nonsense isn't it
postmodernist called [ __ ] on that
first and foremost and that's why
Marxist to this day hate them fredric
jameson a very famous professor at Duke
devoted an entire book in the 1980s to
saying that post-modernism has
distracted us from the real work of
social change and revolution Noam
Chomsky has is still irritated by
post-modernism it says the same thing it
distracts us from what is
and what is really necessary if you are
in the working class you must by your
very nature work for revolution if you
were a capitalist that means something
essentially bad about you as for the
Enlightenment and individualism that
one's hard to take because the
Enlightenment gave us science and
science in the nineteenth century gave
us this thing called scientific racism
now were these marginal scientists were
these quack doctors and quack scientists
no these were all the major scientists
and all the major universities they were
the ones studying skulls measuring
skulls measuring noses measuring
craniums and saying oh those are black
people and those are Irish people and
those are Caucasians and they all have
different characteristics based on their
nature that was a scientific product
that resulted in this thing called
eugenics in the 1920s and 1930s
which resulted by the way in the
sterilization of 50,000 people
involuntarily by court order mostly
women was that done by quack doctors and
marginal figures no pretty much every
major not just scientist but
intellectual in this country operating
in Harvard and Yale and Columbia and
Berkeley and Stanford were sympathetic
or proponents of eugenics these were
scientists who believed this was true
that there were people who were
genetically inferior and that needed to
be bred out of the human race that was
the product of science do you know do
you know where Hitler and the Nazis got
their ideas about Jews and about eugenic
ijen eugenics from American scientists
there was a big interplay interchange
between American and German scientists
in the 1930s the Nazis got most of their
ideas from scientists from this country
this was a consensus view among
scientists that there were certain races
of people that were inferior to others
so one of the interesting things about
post-modernism is that we if I am one
don't believe that there's any true
reading of a text but all I can say is
that my reading of the texts in question
here of Foucault Dario Eliot art and the
rest is radically different than Steven
I can also say that my reading is much
more common than his now you can you can
believe me or not but what I ask you to
do is do something that most of the
critics other than Stephen of
post-modernism have not done is to read
the texts read the text I don't think
Jordan Peterson is read more than maybe
half a book of it I have never heard any
any citation any quotes I mean Stephen
actually offers quotes he's actually
read the text so I respect him for that
that's why I'm debating him but Sam
Harris Jordan Peterson the rest of these
people who go around yelling about
post-modernism they've never once quoted
any of these people read the text
Foucault is not actually difficult
Derrida is but that's what you have to
do you won't have to engage with this
and there's a lot of miss reading that I
think might be deliberate all right I
second that II is's point about reading
the post modern thinkers absolutely this
of course is part of a commitment to
liberal education and it is the
modernists who give you liberal
education the reason why you read this
side of the debate and that side of the
debate is that it's essential for every
individual to train his or her judgment
this is a John Stuart Mill point it's a
one that he was drawing on with John
Locke Michele de Montaigne Galileo and
the others
all right so absolutely that is a
modernist position to be second what we
do find though is that the postmoderns
do not offer that advice themselves
instead what you find explicitly in the
postmodern educators when they take the
high theory and apply it to educational
practice is one sided reading texts
explicitly so so Stanley fish for
example when a leading literary
postmodern theorists was taught it was a
was engaged with this issue of John
Stuart Mill's liberal education thesis
that if we're going to properly train
young people to think for themselves as
individuals they need to hear arguments
from both in all sizes of eights so they
can make up their own individual minds
and fish's response was to say that is
the stupidest thing I have ever heard
you do not want your students to read
the others
you want to squelch the other side's
arguments and that is part of the
commitment to of post-modernism that
you're not interested in training reason
you're not interested in training
individual judgment instead once truth
is out once individual judgment is out
what you have is the movement and your
value agenda your value agenda is a
subjective commitment that you have have
acquired and the important thing is to
you know in a world that you see as a
zero-sum power struggle to use your
power to advance your value so if you
are a professor and you have some power
over your students you don't want to
take a chance that they will read the
other side and come to the wrong
conclusion right from your perspective
fish's colleague at Duke also a
colleague of jameson took this one step
forward and i have the quotation i'm
happy to send it to anyone or he says
explicitly as opposed modernist i am not
interested in truth i am not interested
in knowledge he puts those in quotes for
creation marcus is my job as a professor
is to help students realize the horror
of this evil capitalist world that we
have arisen and and all of the negative
things that have come out of the modern
world and to train them to be activists
to go out and fight the the world so I
agree with Thaddius Russell but I think
Fatih is on this point is actually a
modernist he is not a post modernist in
urging people to read both sides of the
arguments the point about science
changing is absolutely true and that's a
very important point because part of the
modernist project has been to say truth
is not a revelation that is handed down
to us once and for all by higher
authorities rather truth is something
that we each have to work at very hard
and in the initial stages of any science
we're going to make a lot of mistakes
and we should be partially committed to
our hypotheses and being open to
alternative interpretations and at
science if it's properly done has to be
a self-correcting process and open-ended
there are lots of things that we know
but there are lots of things that we
don't yet know and part of the modernist
project is to be self-critical about
exactly how much evidence one has for or
against a given project
but if you're a postmodernist and you
think evidence doesn't matter it's all
just subjective narratives you are not
going to train those skills part of the
modern project is to say oh I believe
this and maybe I over believed it but
here are some good logical arguments
against my position to be open-minded
and to say I have individual agency I
can change my mind and reject my own or
my former beliefs and come to believe
something else if I see myself as an
avatar of my group and I'm just part of
a group advocacy then I am NOT going to
engage in that process so what I would
say in tears of all of the abuses of
psychiatry and I agree entirely that
those are horrific but think of it this
way the fact that some psychiatrists
were willing to use state power and
authoritarian methods in the name of
their quasi scientific theories consider
an analogy to nutrition of course there
are lots of kooky nutritional theories
and what we should do in an ongoing
basis is critique those and so forth but
the issue is if I have a nutritional
theory and I start forcing down your
throat food that I think is good for you
I might have a bad nutritional theory
right and that should be criticized but
the issue here is unforseen food down
your throat right that's what we should
be focused on so the fact that bad
scientists using authoritarian power
we're forcing their views on other
people does not mean that there's no
such thing for example as good nutrition
and that we shouldn't continue to do the
science of nutrition to say oh it's all
just theories and so forth but rather we
need better science
[Applause]
well thanks to both and now we go to the
Q&A portion of the evening and I I want
to exercise moderators prerogative to
throw a couple of questions that you at
you each and start with you Stephen
Thaddeus mentioned two writers that you
have an address that was Thomas das and
Thomas Kuhn would you regard them as
leftist and would you regard them as
post modernist all right take the
microsites I'm Mike Mike yeah sorry
reminder Thomas says politically is
libertarian yeah and my understanding is
that he is a moderate skeptic when it
comes to epistemological and
metaphysical views he believes that
human beings are are real things they're
not just social constructs that there is
a difference between psychological
health and psychological illness even
though he wants to whom I understand he
recognized that this is still something
that we are in the infancy of and his
politics he is a broadly libertarian
okay on yet Thomas Kuhn it is important
to structure of scientific revolutions
book I do see him as the most important
philosopher of science in the 1960s and
he is definitely the one that all of the
post modernists I think correctly cite
so in chapters 10 and chapter 13 of that
book he says yeah I have this this
analysis scientists have changed their
mind about stuff so therefore the
argument that Thaddeus gave us that's
exactly the right but what he doesn't
does is draw the conclusion is that
therefore we have to start saying that
science is really not about the truth
it's about something else and and then
in chapter 13 he goes on to say that
therefore means that we can't say that
science has progressed so there's no
such thing as scientific progress so we
are not in any better off come to the
19th century 20th century 16th century
and so forth and Kuhn is part of a
coterie of deeply skeptical thinkers of
the
time willard van orman quine harvard
philosopher for example so you know I
really want to believe that there are
subatomic particles in the scientific
project but from my philosophical
perspective the Homeric gods and
whatever the scientists are talking
about right now I can't say that one of
them is any better than any other Paul
Feyerabend also publishing at exactly
the same time and a student of karl
popper's we'll leave that one to the
side but Paul fire Robin at the same
time drawing extraordinarily a a
sceptical conclusion saying the best of
modern medicine as it has it been
achieved in the 1960s and witchcraft I
don't see any epistemological
superiority of one to the other and that
is exactly the postmodern epistemology
and Kuhn is part of that package any
comment from you Thaddeus on that
completely different than my reading of
those works and I don't think you'll
find many people who have studied the
works would agree with Stephens
interpretation of this I'm just you'd
have to check this yourself
I yeah so it's it's very hard to respond
to things that just are don't comport at
all with my readings do you want me to
respond to the question about kuhn and
saws if you would like to if you don't
want to i saw is clearly libertarian we
agree on that kuhn not he does not say
that there is no progress in science
there was no such thing as in fact he
argued explicitly against relativism in
fact he doesn't take a radical position
like I do so yeah I I don't see a lot of
this in the work itself okay my question
I will send quotations to anybody yeah
okay please do because of youth adieus
is where I got from Flex I mentioned you
before you when you arrived at I was
excited by the research you've done into
World War two and whether it was really
a necessary war and I listened to your
interview the first interview who did
with Dave Smith
we were actually telling him and I was
struck by your words I
them down that the argument has to be
airtight
about World War two you said airtight
and then though words I am now
completely convinced and this is a
fairly new thing for me and then you
said again completely convinced
emphasize that Western intervention in
World War two killed way way way more
people than it's saved
we're not going to debate that issue
tonight but my question to you is if I
hear a postmodernist say twice that he's
got an airtight case and that he's
completely convinced then I wonder what
the heck is the difference between me
and that guy if he's completely
convinced right so I am operating as a
historian within a modernist frame so
that's where Steven was actually
somewhat right about me okay so to
convince other historians and peep and
the general public you have to operate
within this particular sphere so post
modernists don't say that there is no
such thing as logic or logic is
irrelevant it is of course quite
relevant in our world it's relevant in
the world i inhabit I come from Columbia
University I am trained by a
professional academics to to work within
that world and this is what Foucault
actually said himself he says I use
reason against rationalism I use the I
use the tools of of power against power
I use their own logic to disrupt their
own logic that's what I'm doing in my
work in history I'm simply using their
evidence their logic to call into
question their basic claims that's what
you meant when you say you were
completely convinced you meant to say I
meant within within the logic of history
yes okay as it is written so far okay
thanks I did you want to come in and
that's even you want yes Thaddeus was
all respect is respect the paradox at
all
skeptics Objectivists and relatives is
wrestle with they do want to say on the
one hand and Thaddeus mentions his
social upbringing I was conditioned to a
large extent by my academic training to
accept logic and evidence right and so
forth but then of course the hardcore
postmodern
are simply going to come back and say
well that's just one community and one
set of standards and why is the logic
and evidence set of standards any better
than any other set of standards and
there is no answer to that within
post-modernism it's just I'm making a
subjective commitment to it and that's
exactly why a two generations later we
have a whole generation of university
students right I think they still are a
loud and noisy minority who are not at
all interested in playing that language
game and that's what they've been taught
language is just a game and you
manipulate logic you manipulate evidence
you use any rhetorical trick in order to
advance your group's value judgment and
they will then say yeah I will be
willing to play that game with you in
this particular context but I'm not
making any claims that it's correct or
not if we're interested in the politics
of individual liberty we want to say no
the evidence is on our side the logic is
on our side and this holds for everybody
not just people who've chosen or been
conditioned to believe a certain set of
definitions I think you just want to
follow up on that so there is nothing in
my book and my work anywhere that is
true I never speak the truth
I'm telling stories I'm telling new
stories or different stories or trying
to anyway new narratives and you can
like them or not I don't think they're
any more true than any other story about
the Holocaust or about world war two now
I use I use evidence that other people
use against them or against the game
that they're playing but I don't claim
that there is that this is an absolute
universal truth that is going to apply
for all time that would be highly
arrogant of me
you want to make okay yes I would like
to be very arrogant
I would like to say that slavery is a
moral abomination what do you think that
yes so what exactly does that get you
right so here's no no so here's no so
here's the answer okay so so there were
so there is that was not what ended
slavery what ended slavery was the
mobilization of hundreds of thousands of
people to kill hundreds of thousands of
other people right that's what ended
slavery the moral abomination part
wasn't influencing the Union soldiers
who went down south most of them were
racist as anybody right and actually
many of them supported slavery they did
it either because they were conscripted
or because they thought it was the only
decent job in town or they simply
supported this idea of the nation-state
we don't know but most importantly and
actually they were more concerned about
the slave power the power of the slave
masters than the slaves themselves the
intellectual moving in Britain Thaddius
against slavery yes did that help end
slavery in the bridge yes it did to some
extent not much though the abolitionist
movement was a minor player I'm talking
about the British movement in England
that ended slavery in South America it
was it was part of it but ok as part of
it but so but here's an important point
though no no so not not in this country
at all though and that's that's a
consensus among well no I know but but
but so here's the interesting thing
about the abolitionist movement Stephen
calls that a triumph of enlightenment
individualistic thinking does anyone
know about who the abolitionists in this
country and in England were and who what
was influencing them and what was really
driving them white what made them
anti-slavery was a deep deep belief in
Christianity in particular in this
country Calvinism the oldest most rigid
most superstitious you could say forms
of Christianity it was not it was not an
Enlightenment movement at all if you
know anything about history of
abolitionism it was as Christian as the
day as long had nothing to do with
science or reason to rationality in fact
it was a very pre-modern movement just
another question for for Thaddeus part
of Thaddeus isn't for a first round of
argumentation was to point out the
terrible state abuses of power in
psychiatry with respect to gays Jews
women and so forth so my question would
be do you think
that those were morally wrong abuses of
state power or do you think that it's a
narrative interpretation that you
believe that those things are wrong but
there are other alternative narrative
narrations that could justify the state
use of power against blacks Jews women
and so for right so morality to me is a
form of superstition so it is an it is
the idea that something applies again to
all people at all times in all places
forever right that that is a religious
idea I hope that's clear I hope it's
clear that you can't prove that you
can't disprove it either but that is a
hell of an arrogant claim that is very
similar to what you find in the Bible
isn't it right that something is going
to apply eternally to all people in all
places I find that incredibly arrogant
now now does this mean that I am NOT
opposed to slavery no I don't want to
live in a society that has slavery in it
because of my values that's a different
thing the morality so what I what I tell
people and I've told my students this
for decades don't don't worry about what
is morally good or morally wrong figure
out what you want what you value and as
a Randi an Objectivist you should
appreciate this it's the politics of
self-interest that I'm preaching here if
you want to live in a society that
includes slavery I'm gonna fight you if
you're gonna try to impose that on me
right if you want to not live in a
society with slavery that's all you need
you don't need to make moral claims do
you if you don't want to live in this
society like that includes slavery you
would have picked up a gun in 1861 and
gone down south maybe or you would
simply have refused by force of arms the
entrance of slave states into the north
so just figure out what you want and
move from there
politically it's just a question of
strategy once you know what your value
is instead of we get stuck in this idea
about what other people should want what
how other people should live which I
find to be not fine to be but I would
submit is the root the origin of
imperialism
not just cultural but political and
military as well you will find in the
case of every imperialist movement every
imperialist General every imperialist
great Conqueror they begin with a claim
that those people over there should live
according to the way that I think
because it is morally right this goes
all the way back to the Crusades right
think about the Crusades a whole bunch
of people thought the people in the
Middle East were living in a bad way in
an immoral way and what happened next
and that goes all the way up to the
present time
every imperialist campaign in from every
country in the history of the world
began with universal truth claims
Universal moralistic truth claims I say
let's get out of the business of that
and let's move toward individualistic
value claims and operating our politics
from that all right thanks and yeah I so
first question please face has a
question go ahead please good this is
for both or either does post-modernism
teach that there are no absolutes so
mathematical let's say Pythagoras
theorem ethical rape is wrong let's say
economic the law of supply and demand
no truths whatsoever I guess that's
mainly well go ahead Seema yes no okay
explanation okay most wanted theory of
language is that language is a social
construct how terms are defined is
arbitrarily as a result of tradition
that applies universally and that is a
universalistic claim but then that just
means that and all of the analytic and
skeptical continental thinkers at the
postmoderns are growing on when they are
getting their first rate PhD education
say explicitly logical truths are true
only because we have decided to make
them true it's a subjective projection
the truth somatoform attic and how we
have defined the axioms are true only
because we have stipulated them to be so
they don't say anything about the way
things are out in the
i I would challenge Stephen or anyone
else to find any of these postmodernist
thinkers that we've discussed saying
anything like that I will send the
quotation okay so they they simply do
not they simply write the history of
these claims like with Kuhn in Coons
case he would he would have written the
history of the Pythagoras theorem and
shown that it was invented by a
particular man at a particular time in
particular place right now is it true
universally we'll all we know is as Kuhn
said that these truth claims within
science get overturned pretty much every
single day even just recently last year
last couple of years they found
something moving in outer space that
didn't comport with the theory of
gravity okay again the idea of you know
the of atoms and spaces between them
that's a relatively new idea which was
craziness before we discovered that or
we think we discovered that no it is
simply this has not ever been a claim by
postmodernists they simply want to be
skeptical not atheistic agnostic about
all these questions
gnostic and skeptical next question hi
my name is Patrick dord and I guess my
question is more for dr. Russell how do
you don't call me doctor alright sorry
daddy is how do you reconcile bad
science with not throwing the baby out
with the bathwater can you unpack that
just a bit I'm not exactly sure as far
as like some of the examples you gave us
like eugenics or scientific racism
running the bathwater okay so so what do
you want do you do you want eugenics do
you want people to be divided by their
gene pools and then the people with
inferior gene pools to be weeded out
from the population no if you do you
want a cure for cancer
then then you might want to support that
right you might want to support that
part of science I do I love medical
advances I love much of medical science
because it makes me healthier makes me
happier it makes me right now again is
that going to be let's think about he
brought up a nutrition and diet right
will those well those methods those
techniques in medical science always be
right the best
to do so now we all believe what that
carbs are terrible for you right and fat
is good for you well remember about 15
years ago when it was just the weather
way around and wait till the next diet
fad and that's just in nutrition so
scientists ask a scientist they're
revising truth all the time all the time
that's what you do as a scientist you
don't get up in the morning and say you
know what we're done with gravity we've
discovered we know the truth we know the
truth and we're done stops stop studying
it no scientists study gravity every
single day all over the world don't they
they study all of the questions that are
that many people think are settled there
are no settled questions this is the
problem with modernist thinking right
they believe that you can get to it you
can get to an end point and find the
truth it's anti-intellectual if we
closed a question that means there is no
studying left to do
that means there's no science left to do
it's also anti science scientists should
be and they day themselves will tell you
this relentlessly skeptical relentlessly
questioning and relentlessly revising
that's what good scientists have always
done don't ask me ask them comment from
you doctor sorry Thaddeus is hey look
call me fat really it's fine you got it
we've been on each other a long time
professor Russell yeah is presenting to
us a false alternative on the one hand
we're supposed to say science means that
everything is fixed final complete
somehow scientists have acquired this
omniscient understanding and then and
only then can we use the words truth
knowledge and certainty but since we
don't have that we should and this is
your bathwater issue throw out the
concepts of truth
throw out the knowledge claims throw out
the claim that we can ever be certain
and that's a false alternative and I
don't want to say it's somewhere in the
middle but proper science is a low-grade
skepticism does have a place in in
science we should every generation every
individual think for ourselves about all
of the claims but the truth is some
people do know more than others some
people have a better understanding of
the evidence than other people do some
people have spent more time they've done
more logic and we do know some things
right in science we know that the Sun
generates Heat
for example we know that gravity is
actually a real force in the world now
when you start with the basic things
those things don't get changed when we
get to very complicated theories of
course then we need to be more
hypothetical more speculative more
probabilistic in our thinking's but
don't think it's an all or nothing there
is no truth or we have absolute infinite
truth right now we're working the
territory next question hi Ted Parris I
just wanted to see if Thaddeus and
Stephen could comment on whether this
summer gets at the distinction between
your views which is that absolutes exist
and absolutes don't exist so there is an
epistemic split between subject and
object in the universe
people perceive things subjectively
there is no objective observer god was
invented to be the objective observer
but because there is no objective
observer there are no absolutes there
can be no absolute truth and when you
talk about morality it's just silly
because morality developed as a way for
people to cooperate in groups and to
have rules of behavior so if you're a
moral realist it's really just silly
because morality differs in every
different culture and group all right
comment you want to comment 15 yeah yeah
so let's take up the issue of morality
and objectivity so let's take the
phenomenon of traffic and the rules that
we have evolved with respect
to traffic and what's the status of
those rules now we could say at one
level driving on the left side of the
road or driving on the right side of the
road there's no God that specifies right
and there's no you know when we started
driving flags that sprang out of the
ground and said thou shalt drive on the
right side of the road so we we decided
those things and so there is with
respect to many moral principles and
moral rules wiggle room and decisions
that are largely operated but the fact
is that human beings are real the fact
is that cars are real the fact is
objectively so that people want to get
various places the facts are that if
people collide with each other in
multi-ton vehicles they will be damaged
so there are objective facts and
objective values that we are trying to
resolve in a social context and we make
rules to say there has to be one side or
the other that's an objective fact if
we're actually going to get to our
places safely so it's a combination of
objective facts objective needs that we
have identified properly that leads us
to make certain decisions but often
there are is wiggle room in those
particular decisions and that's where
the so-called subjective element comes
in come in I second what you said my
questions for dr. Hicks I'm gonna frame
it in terms of an intuition pump so we
don't have to argue about the parameters
so imagine a world where there are
advances in neuroscience and psychology
that we can say by age 10 that this
individual will be a sexual sadist or a
psychopathic killer to put it
differently we can say with scientific
certainty that these individuals will
impinge on the freedom of others if they
are left to be free so my question is
what happens to your epistemological
claim that all humans have a birthright
or I forget how you said it but
essentially a right to freedom well the
right to freedom is not infringed
everybody still has the right to freedom
but your right to freedom
where other people's freedoms are being
infringed upon so your SATA masochistic
killer they're not there's not your salt
that's right so once they they don't
have a right an absolute right to engage
in those kinds of actions so what I
would then say is it would be a normal
police thing if you have good knowledge
that someone is likely to commit a crime
than you engage in surveillance but you
engage in surveillance to the extent
that you have good evidence you get
search warrants and so forth so I
wouldn't say yeah in this science
fiction scenario the police should start
following that guy around very closely
now there's not going to be any prior
restraint but yes you put a security
cordon around that guy to prevent him
from engaging in in the actions not very
libertarian of you I must say
then it sounds like Minority Report to
me except worse you with eugenics added
to it yeah next question hi my question
is for Thaddeus I wanted to follow up on
a question that came up earlier about
science whether science has has made any
definitive claims yet or whether it's
always evolving and Steven brought up a
few examples my my favorite is the earth
is round so I want what I'm trying I'm
trying I would like daddies for you to
explain to me how to wrap my mind around
this in a postmodern way so let me be
very specific
how would you or how could I think of
the world is round as not true in a
universal way right and that seems to me
a scientific claim it was it was
achieved through scientific methods but
how could it be you seem to be saying
that it's true maybe within a context
but not outside that context or within
within the context of certain claims but
not universally true so how how do you
wrap your mind around this idea that the
earth is round
this claim the earth is round is not
universally true yeah well I would just
say just
okay well doesn't matter doesn't matter
please no heckling for the audience
thank you
was that a flatterer throughout there
get them out of here that's just not
true it's just not scientifically true
we know this okay okay okay right it's
not know she's actually right so first
of all so of so first it was flat and
everybody was completely sure it was
flat everybody right and you were burned
at the stake if you disbelieved that and
then everybody believed it was a perfect
sphere and this is kind of getting what
you're at right I think where you're
coming from right and now it's sort of
oblong and bumpy and not exactly round
right well here's the question then
should we then stop studying the
question of whether the earth is round
no if you're a scientist you study
everything you keep researching and
maybe this is not answering your
question but claiming the my question
had nothing to do with half the the
exact degree to which it's round it's
just that it's not flat all right we
know it's round it meets on the other
end but do you see how is it that's all
that my question needs but no no but do
you see but do you see how the shape of
the earth keeps changing according to
science so it was flat and then it was a
perfect perfect sphere and now it's a
bumpy oblong thing do we stop studying
it I say no if you're an actual
scientist okay okay so in response to
this question I would be willing to say
the shape of the earth is an objective
fact right but it's not a universal
truth and the reasons for that are
individualistic that knowledge resides
in individual minds and what you know
depends on what you as an individual
have studied and learned now it is an
objective fact that the earth is
spherical for those who have looked at
the evidence and so forth but there are
lots of people who have not looked at
the evidence so it's not a truth for
them if you ask them is the earth
spherical or not and they're you know
four years old I never thought about it
the right answer for that person would
be to say I don't know to be agnostic on
it so it's not yet a truth for that
person because they've not processed
even though for those who have studied
it it's objectively true
that the earth is spherical um I'm
afraid that's gonna have to be the lat
we've got one more minute okay one final
question thanks good yeah
hi this is directed to um mr. Russell
don't call me mr. professor Russell okay
do you believe anything actually exists
bacio do you know anything actually
exists I'm not sure I exist anymore what
I don't can you a little bit more of
that I'm not exactly sure what you're
asking me what do you mean actually
actually exude believe anything is real
okay so I don't know is my answer I am
an agnostic on this question it is a
possibility that you're not there and
I'm not here I don't operate in the
world like that I don't walk down the
street thinking oh my god I might
disappear I might not be real right I'm
I'm operating in the world that my head
is in okay I just know that there have
been so many fundamental beliefs like
that that were believed across societies
that have not just been revised but
radically overthrown that I remain
skeptical what everything like again the
Sun revolving around the earth everyone
believed that everyone believed that the
floor with this floor was completely
solid and had no spaces in it right so
even on that yes I'm just say let's be
skeptical let's be actual scientists
that's what post-modernism is I'm
Stephen maybe you want to address that
in your final summation that'd be good
uh so you have five minutes okay so
here's an essentialist claim that's
often made every year by this thing
called the IRS they say to you well
you're an American you were born on this
this piece of land and that means you
need you must because you are an
American essentially fundamentally you
must give us your money
that's an essentialist claim the
nation-state as a born of essentialism
too if you're born on a piece of land in
a particular time you are a German or
you're an American or you're a Canadian
or whatever it is and that means x y&z
about you it also means that you have to
serve your country every once in a while
go to war and fight and die
now postmodernist would say excuse me
very much
what why on earth just by dumb luck I
was born here I had no choice in this
right but that means that I'm an
American and that I have all these
obligations and duties to this place I
didn't even choose to live in right well
this modernist would say let's let's ask
some questions about that let's let's
write the history of it let's study the
history of that's what Foucault would
say and he would find out that oh no
actually you know this was a land that
was conquered by one people over another
people and they imposed this
nation-state on it and by the way that
happened about 5 minutes ago in world
history if you look at it right the
nation-state is a very very new
phenomenon it's only about a couple
hundred years old but we all walk around
thinking like oh my god I am American in
my soul don't we don't we Germans
thought I am German in my soul and that
means all these things about me what a
fiction that is quite obviously and I
would say a pretty destructive fiction
too so if you look at all the casualties
of the last 200 years in the world
including just just all the killings all
the murders in the world I'm gonna say
that the nation state and people acting
on behalf of the nation-state have
killed more human beings in the last 200
years then all the other actors combined
there's no doubt about that especially
in the 20th century the culmination the
pinnacle of modernism and scientism and
a belief in reason and rationality the
20th century was nothing but killing
fields the greatest murders of human
beings on a mass scale ever world war
one world war two the anti-colonial
revolts of Vietnam goes on and on and on
all again conducted by engineers with
state power acting very rationally
studying things looking at maps you know
who ran the Vietnam War right guys from
Harvard
all the best and the brightest didn't
they there was their idea the Vietnam
War oh and they're also the ones who
invented napalm and they're also the
ones who built the airplanes that drop
the bombs all in the name of science and
reason and rationality and improving
these people lifting them up from their
savage pre civilized existence into the
modern world that's what was said has
always been said about imperialism
that's what it is it's good for them
we're raising them up into modern into
the modern world we're gonna give them
the advances of science we're gonna do
that by killing half of them first and
then we're gonna put them in our schools
which are also run by scientists and
engineers and rational reasonable people
so again I really like some things that
science and reason and rationality by
the way I love Reason magazine so much
except for the name of the damn thing
let's work on that
so yeah reason rationality science have
given me medicine that I use that I
really enjoy I love flying in airplanes
it's great to just get in this thing and
I end up in another city the next in a
few hours
fantastic but as I said before those
airplanes are and have been used for
other purposes
pretty nasty purposes and will be in the
future most likely the atom bomb we love
that thing don't we
who is that invented by scientists so
let's at least be skeptical whenever it
is claimed that scientists are right and
science is true let's be skeptical of
this thing that that I think who
invented the term scientism oh it was
this guy named FA Hyack a great
libertarian scientism he said is the
belief in science as a religion
the belief that scientists have access
to truth that the rest of us don't that
science arrives at universal eternal
truth that is scientism the idea that
even gravity the theory of gravity will
never change we'll never be revised has
already been proven false
every major scientific claim has been
revised or overthrown and again that's
what scientists do if you're really a
scientist or really a postmodernist but
most importantly post-modernism and a
belief in personal liberty I think
should be twinned should be paired and
could create a brand new movement and
maybe a new iteration of libertarianism
that might actually make me for the
first time in my life
identify as a libertarian so we'll see
thank you for listening and I hope you
hope you vote for the proposition I'd
like to do a second dad's remarks about
the horrors of 20th century political
history and certainly there have been
abuses up and down every continent and
so forth the problem is not science
the problem is collectivism you look at
the death tolls the Nazis the fascists
the Communists in China the Communists
in the Soviet Union all of them were as
young people committed to a strongly
collectivist anti individualistic
anti-liberal methodology as a secondary
overlay way they would use pragmatically
when they thought it helpful various
scientific theories they would draw upon
science in order to serve their
collectivistic ends so the issue the
issue here is not science in places
where individuality is respected its
science being abused by collectivists
now the connection then to postmoderns
is that the postmodern czar in their
understanding of human nature and their
understanding of human cognition
actually don't believe in human
cognition in their understanding of
human whatever it is
we do with our minds and our
understanding of human values are deeply
and thoroughly collectivistic if we want
the fruits of science we do as this one
gentleman says that we need to sort the
good from the bad the only way we're
going to sort the good from the bad is
by ongoing commitment to doing the
experimenting doing the logic doing the
reason but we have to respect the
individuals all the way through science
combined with individualism has brought
the modern world and I'm sure we have
all seen the charts you go the timeline
of human history when humans were tribal
and pre-scientific
and mystical religious and so forth
flatline and all of the indicators of
human wellbeing and it's not until we
get to the early modern world where
individualism starts to be taken
seriously the the belief in capacity for
all individuals to think for themselves
to make their own judgments that
individual pursuit of happiness is a
universal birthright and we then
seriously start to try to extend it not
only to the white males who first came
up with the idea but to non-white males
to women to people of different
religions that is when we started to
make progress and the progress has been
astonishing so there are facts in the
world with hard work and rational
commitment we can come to know them at
the some time we do need to be aware of
our limits and not be hubristic in
overstating what we do and what we do
not know but what we do know is that
there is one philosophy in the entire
history of human beings that has enabled
us to enjoy the prosperity and the
tolerance and the extended lifestyles
and all of the gadgets that make us make
us happy to be living in the 21st
century and we have learned also the
negative lessons and I think fad has
half learned some of those negative
lessons right yes the abuses of state
power are wrong but notice that he is
agreeing that abuses of state power are
wrong that is a universalist claim
that's an Objectivist claim he is making
about
of state power and I don't think he's
going to want to zou and maybe he would
want to say it's only my personal
preference that abuses of state power
are all wrong thing we want something
more than that and we can do it right
but it takes a certain philosophy
now the postmoderns don't believe as
referred to tonight right that we can
say that there's a difference between
reality and unreality if you think that
everything is a subject of reality than
any sort of politics of individual
liberty is not going to matter to you if
you don't think that reason is competent
then you're not going to try very hard
to be rational and if we're not going to
try very hard to be rational we're not
going to get science we're not going to
get democracy we're not going to get a
free market all of those depend on
people being rational and so forth if we
don't believe that individuals are the
units of value that each person has
their own inherent dignity they're the
right to the pursuit of happiness then
we're not going to tolerate people who
are different from us so tolerance is a
deep universal respect for other
people's individuality and that has to
be held as an objective universal
principle the only places and the only
times in history where we have made
progress and the progress has been real
the status of women the status of gays
the status of blacks and all of the
other races the fact that we can be in a
city like New York and just look at all
that has been achieved right
post-modernism is never going to build a
skyscraper instead what it's going to do
is argue that the skyscraper is a
phallic symbol and
a tool of yes white male imperialism and
we know the rest of this story so please
vote no well please register your final
vote on your smartphone post-modernism
is necessary for a politics of
individual liberty please vote and
meanwhile I do want to announce that
Thaddeus will be hosting a fattiest
Russell's unregistered live event if you
put that into a search engine I guess
you'll find it that will feature Dave
Smith whom you heard tonight as well as
nickel SP who you also saw tonight you
want those three guys back then you can
see it tomorrow night in Brooklyn
Thaddeus Russell's unregistered live
event tickets tickets are still
available
with Dave Smith and Nicholas be next
month Monday August 12th we are will
have another debate on Bitcoin I do urge
you to buy your tickets now that Bitcoin
event is selling out fast the resolution
will be Bitcoin is poorly suited to the
purpose of becoming any nation's main
medium of exchange defending that
resolution will be George Celgene
against savety and a moose that's August
12th our debate on Bitcoin Monday August
12th on Tuesday September 10th Dave
Smith will be back again not only giving
us a warm-up act but also debating in
this case debating Nicolas saw walk on
the future of the Libertarian Party they
will be doing double dipping that
evening that's August September 10th and
then afterwards at our home two blocks
away the loft apartment that I share
with a suckle we're going to host a
fundraising event for the Mises caucus
of the Libertarian Party and Michael
heist will be there I will be there Dave
Smith and a couple of other people that
will be hosted at our home just two
blocks away
we'll give you the address then if you
show or you want to go we will be
posting that event on a website very
soon but for you to come to that
charitable event on behalf of the Mises
caucus of the Libertarian Party on
Monday October 7th we're going to have a
debate on drug use
Jacob sullen of Reason magazine what's a
better name for the magazine unreason
what do you think post-modernism
postmodern magazine Reason magazine
Jacob solemn will be defending the
resolution a little a little bit of a
mouthful but he wanted to be careful
except for laws prohibiting the sale of
drugs to minors and driving while
impaired all laws that penalised drug
production distribution possession and
use should be abolished along with
special sin taxes on drugs covers the
map pretty pretty well there and
Thaddeus is gonna vote YES on the
resolution I can see and he will be
debating former New York Times reporter
Alex Berenson author of tell your
children the truth about marijuana
mental illness and violence no we have
the results
so the the yes vote on the resolution
began at and we take it to the second
decimal place because my man Yuri who
developed program was careful 7.07
percent voted yes initially that rose to
eighteen point one eight percent so that
means that the yes vote gained 11.11%
that's the number to beat 11.11% the
initial know started at 33.33% and rose
to sixty seven point sixty eight percent
to a 34 feet
so uh but again both of you gained votes
congratulations however the tootsie roll
goes to Steven
[Applause]
[Music]